let's end the show with some good vibe
John Cena now holds a world record uh
proving uh just how good he treats his
fans yeah that's right the WWE champ
holds the Guinness world record for the
most wishing grants through Make-A-Wish
Foundation offering children who have
been diagnosed with a critical illness a
chance to make a special wish through
different organizations according to the
Guinness World Records John has made
about 650 children wishes come true
becoming the foundation's most requested
celebrity so in honor of his
heartwarming accomplishments so let's
take a look back at John making wishes
come true stay healthy stay safe we love
you all thanks for being part of the
show
so tell me who was it
we all come from different walks of life
we all do different things but we're in
this room for one common goal and that's
because we want to make dreams come true
he's just an incredible individual you
could see that with the amount of time
that he spends with each child very
happy to hear my guest awesome
John has granted more wishes than any
other celebrity in the history of the
Make-A-Wish Foundation
always said that being a part of make a
wish and being able to contribute to the
Make-A-Wish Foundation is something
extra special oh my goodness this one's
so much heavier how do you carry this
around a little bit
let's where these come from The champ is
here champ is here right now I got a
question for you can we get a picture
together yes
[Music]
they could have chosen to wish for
anything and they've chosen to meet him
and he understands that and he
understands how life transforming these
experiences are you were somebody's wish
I mean that that doesn't even sound
right to say but it certainly makes you
feel good